-It is always so great to see you.
Gosh, that was so fun. -Oh, my. Isn't he the best?
-The two of you -- Everyone -- Together.
It's was the most fun thing ever.
I just also love how we know each other now so well
that you're like,
"That's very cool, but it's too cool for you."
[ Laughter ]
And you were right. I'm like, "Yeah, you're right."
-No, well, I just -- I feel like you and Noah --
same person to me.
Like, you guys are just the same person.
You guys just -- Same energy, same vibe.
Noah's not cool enough to get a call from LeBron James.
-Yeah, no, he's not... -He's not.
-You brought a picture of you and Eeyore.
-Yes. That's my rabbit. [ Audience awws ]
-I mean, stop.
And you think this is the cutest thing ever,
but then you brought another one to top this cute.
This is you and your dog and your bunny in bed together.
-Yes. Hugging.
[ Audience awws ] Yeah.
He, uh -- He is a genius.
And like I said, he buzzes when he gets really happy.
So he'll just -- Right behi-- He'll come up to me,
and I'll be going to work, and he'll look at me. "Bzz!"
And I'll be like, "Alright. Like, he's coming with me."
I pick him up put him in his stroller,
push him onto set, and it's, like, the best life.
-You -- I'm sorry. Wait. You put him in his stroller?
-Yeah.
-You put him in his stroller and stroll him on set?
-Yes. Car seat and all. It's a situation. Yeah.
-We talked about this last time you were on the show.
We were talking about, is there anyone surprising
that loves you from "Stranger Things"?
And you're like, "Lots of people. It's crazy."
'Cause, I mean, everyone loves you and loves the show.
But Mariah Carey's son loved you so much
and Mariah Carey loves you,
and they carved you into a pumpkin.
-Yeah, I saw this and thought -- Oh --
And, by the way, love Mariah,
but, like, her son is the cutest thing ever.
I was like, "Oh, I need to meet her son..."
and, you know, do the pose
and, like, make him think that I have superpowers.
And we met -- And Monroe and Moroccan --
who are just the most brilliant little children.
And then, obviously, I just, like, met Mariah
and was just like, "Oh."
Like, we connected. It was just like a --
-You connected with Mariah Carey?
-Yeah. "Mimi."
[ Laughter ]
-Does Mimi ever text you? -We texted today.
Oh, yeah, she called me today. Oh, yeah.
-Are we still playing the game or is this real?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I -- I mean, we're -- The reason is because
she grew up, you know, in the public eye,
and we have connected just on so many different levels.
But also I love the way
that she leads her life with so much power,
and she has so much knowledge and she's so wise.
And she's just been an incredible guiding light for me.
And then we connected, and then I go over to her house
and I'll be, like, eating dinner,
and she'll come around and she'll be like --
[ Harmonizing ]
I'll be like...
-No, for real?! -No, it's a real thing.
It's not like -- People are like --
No, no, no, no, no.
She does it when we're eating Chinese food.
-Wait! What?! -It's wild.
-She's coming on. I want to talk to her about this.
-Oh, yeah, but don't -- Yeah. -She just has to do it?
-Oh, no, she'll just do it, and you're just kind of like --
And she'll just be talking to you and she's like...
♪ Always be my baby ♪
-You'll be like, "You just said that?"
-I'm like, "Hold on." -Wait. So you guys are buds?
-Buds. -Do you ever sing with her?
-We have sung together, yeah, yeah.
-Have you ever -- Like, for real --
-Like, in her studio, sung together.
-What?! -Yeah!
-Wait! Is there something --
Could something be in the works? -Potentially.
I mean, there's always -- She's always doing something.
She's, like, the most -- the busiest woman ever.
I call her, and she's in the middle of, like, changing the --
I'm like, "Oh, hold on one second. Can we talk?"
She's like, "Oh, one second, darling.
I'm performing at MSG." I'm like, "I'm sorry?"
-Yeah, exactly. -It's the most incredible --
-And I'm just like, "Can we hang out?"
And then I'll just go over, and we'll sing together.
It's the most magical.
She is the most talented singer ever.
-Mariah Carey and Millie Bobby Brown -- maybe a collab?
-Potentially. I don't know. [ Laughter ]
-This is the biggest scoop I've ever gotten
on "The Tonight Show" ever. I love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I would buy that in two seconds. I cannot wait.
Again, I don't want to take credit
for anyone's career, besides LeBron James,
but when you were here for "Enola Holmes,"
the first one, I was like -- I went in the dressing room.
I'm like, "Millie, I absolutely love this.
It is a smash. It is a hit. I think this is the b--"
And you're like, "Oh, really? Bah-bah-bah."
And it became the biggest thing in the world
I feel like because I put that vibe out there.
-You manifested it, Jimmy.
-I did, right? It's so funny. It is so good.
It's well-written. It's charming.
So now you're back with "2." -I am.
-"Enola Holmes 2." -I am.
-November 4th. Next Friday.
[ Cheers and applause ] -Yeah.
-And you're producing this, as well.
-Yes. -I mean, this is just
the best thing ever. -It really is.
This is something that I have been wanting to do
since I was little -- I mean, 13, 14.
I read the book series, and I went to my dad
and said I wanted to make it.
So for me, my older sister and I have
collaborated on this project
and made sure that it came to light in the most authentic
and British way as possible.
And, you know, I never had, growing up,
a female British lead to look up to.
And Enola is that for me.
And it's been an amazing experience creating it.
-You were saying to me, like, so many little girls --
That's, like, one of the coolest parts of this.
Little girls coming up to you and going like --
Or parents going, "My daughter is obsessed with Enola Holmes."
-It's so funny, and I'll be like --
You know, they'll be like, "Can you say it?"
And I'm like, "'Tis I." And they're like, "Aah!"
But it's so fun because,
you know, there will be kids that are doing their little --
They're American, and they're doing their
little English accent, and they're like,
"My brother Sherlock Holmes."
I'll be like, "Oh, God." I love it.
It's just the most incredible feeling.
I mean, Blake Lively -- she text me once.
I mean, I know that you're... You know of them.
-Oh, Blake. Are you kidding me?
She calls me. -She calls you.
We're not on a calling basis at all.
-We're over texting. We want to go voice-to-voice.
-One conversation... -Walkie-talkie.
[ Laughter ]
-Bedroom-to-bedroom. "Hey, you there?"
-Flashing mirrors back and forth like, "Hi, Blake."
-Morse code. -Yeah.
-No. I was like -- You know, she's like, "Hey, listen.
My daughter wants to wear --
to basically just live in an Enola Holmes costume."
And I was like, "Well, I don't have any for you."
And she was like, "How can I get a dress that looks like it?
Because she wants to be Enola just for her life."
And I was like, "Okay, well, maybe go on Etsy,
type in '1800 dresses.'"
Because I can't even get the dresses. She wants --
And I was like, "You don't want to wear --"
I was like, "Let her know she doesn't want to wear the dress.
These are corseted." -So you have at least --
You have at least two Halloween costumes.
People are dressing as you for Halloween. Three probably.
-Now I just stay in, Halloween. -You don't even leave the house.
-My little sister's like, "Can you c--"
I'm like, "No! No, no!" I know. Well, bec-- Yeah.
I mean, one year, actually, on season two of "Stranger Things,"
all us kids went together but as different things.
I was Harley Quinn, and Finn was a whoopie cushion.
It was the funniest thing.
And everybody turned up on the -- Ding, dong!
Trick or treat!
"Stranger Things" kids? The whole thing.
-Yeah, 'cause everyone together. You're like, "Oh, boy."
-Yeah, it's not really happening, but it is.
-When the Beatles travel together,
they're still Beatles, yeah.
What can we say? What is "Enola Holmes 2"?
What's happening in this movie?
-So, this time around we indulge in a real story
about matchstick girls, and they --
It's a real strike
that was led in late 1800s by Sarah Chapman.
And we get to really uncover that mystery
as to why these girls were being treated so badly.
-Boy, I love that. -Yes.
And I think it's really great because it is shining a light
on female workers and protecting them and their rights,
and it's an amazing story, and obviously you get to
go along with it with her video camera,
her video diary I say.
Enola's video diary. "Hey, guys!"
She's like a blogger on YouTube.
-Yeah, basically -- Just talking to camera.
-Go along with Enola and figure it out.
-You crush it. I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Millie Bobby Brown in "Enola Holmes 2."
Take a look at this.
-Whoo!
-[ Thud ] -Ugh!
-My mistake.
I should have warned you I was opening it.
-Don't. No.
-Dare I ask?
♪♪
-Aah! [ Gasps ]
Good afternoon.
May I ask a favor?
♪♪
-Never mind. Tell me everything.
[ Cheers and applause ] -Yeah! That's right.
Millie Bobby Brown, everyone.
"Enola Holmes 2" is available on Netflix November 4th.
Michael Imperioli joins us next. Stick around, everybody.
Hi, Eeyore! Go to sleep!